on this wednesday night gut-wrenching
pleas from victims of gun violence
i left my daughter at that school
and that decision will haunt me for the
rest of my life powerful messages to
american lawmakers on restricting
firearms monkey pox concerns a warning
to canadian travelers
relief for some ukrainians welcome to
canada thank you
we follow those fleeing war for a fresh
start in canada
and trouble on the road to the world cup
the problem's off the pitch for canada's
men's soccer team
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the voices of
those whose lives have been destroyed by
gun violence it happens so often in the
u.s it barely makes headlines but two
weeks after the school shooting in
uvalde texas where police waited outside
while the gunman massacred children with
an automatic weapon people from that
small town are raising their voices they
went to washington today to testify
before u.s lawmakers
what they said is difficult to hear a
pediatrician described what the bullets
from the ar-15 the gun that was used did
to the children
two children whose bodies have been
pulverized by bullets fired at them
decapitated
whose flesh had been ripped apart
that the only clue at their identities
was a blood splattered cartoon clothes
still clinging to them i chose to be a
pediatrician i chose to take care of
children
keeping them safe from preventable
diseases i can do
but making sure our children are safe
from guns
that's the job of our politicians and
leaders
what are politicians prepared to do
about it the u.s justice department said
today it will conduct a full
investigation into the law enforcement
response that day
that of course will do nothing to change
the epidemic of gun violence in the u.s
jackson proskow has our top story
tonight
something needs to really change
desperate pleas for action from those
who've lost so much like the parents of
10 year old lexi rubio killed in uvalde
i left my daughter at that school
and that decision will haunt me for the
rest of my life maya cirillo survived
the texas massacre by covering herself
in the blood of her best friend and
playing dead i
thought he was going to come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and put it all over me
zaneta everhart's son barely survived
the racist attack on a buffalo
supermarket what in the world is wrong
with this country
children should not be armed with
weapons each begged lawmakers to do
something knowing there's little hope
the u.s will adopt serious gun controls
republicans won't budge again insisting
guns are not the problem just listen to
the party whip who survived a mass
shooting himself i go back to september
11th and airplanes were used that day
as the weapon to kill thousands of
people and to inflict terror on our
country
there wasn't a conversation about
banning airplanes
[Applause]
yet there is still hope that small
measures may find support in this moment
in a symbolic move democrats in the
house are set to vote on multiple gun
reforms including raising the minimum
age for purchasing semi-automatic rifles
to 21 and barring large capacity
magazines these measures make american
safer matters it's a good package each
one of them is very important
cumulatively they make a big difference
the reforms have almost no chance of
passing the senate and becoming law but
democratic senator chris murphy is
leading negotiations with republicans on
more modest measures we're continuing to
work
through the details of a
of an agreement we're not there yet but
my
continued hope and belief is that we can
find common ground the end result could
be enhanced screening for younger gun
buyers and encouraging but not mandating
states to adopt red flag laws far short
of what gun control advocates have long
called for i won't agree to anything
that doesn't make a meaningful
difference that doesn't save
[Applause]
lives in this country the families who
spoke to lawmakers today say they simply
want to make sure that their loss is not
in vain and they haven't given up hope
of a deal to raise the minimum age to
buy an ar-15 style assault rifle to 21 a
step that potentially could have stopped
the shootings in both buffalo and uvalde
donna
jackson proskow thanks
now to ukraine troops battling russian
forces in a key city in eastern ukraine
appear to be on the cusp of retreat
these satellite images from sevier
rodonesque show
significant damage after constant
russian attacks ukrainian soldiers
defending the city are said to be
fighting for every centimeter and may
have to pull back the city is the last
major metropolitan area still under
ukrainian control in luhansk province
nearly 5 million ukrainians have fled
because of russia's attack that's
according to the united nations more
than 120 000 of them have been approved
to come here to canada and this week new
brunswick welcomed the newest arrivals
170 people and 17 pets our jeff semple
was on the flight with them and brings
us this exclusive report
these ukrainians have just escaped the
horrors of their home
arriving here to poland to submit their
paperwork and book their ticket for a
new life where are you going now we are
going
to canada the group of around 170
ukrainians is catching a flight to
moncton arranged by the new brunswick
government with help from a canadian
veterans group we see a lot of people
small children
and
some elderly as well so
vulnerable populations that need our
help this family fled the fighting near
harkeev their hometown now controlled by
russian forces
there was so much bombing she says i
huddled with my son on the floor for 30
hours
i am happy i
[Music]
really i am happy emotionally they're
torn between excitement for what lies
ahead
and heartbreak for those left behind
part of my heart will always be here
olena koroniska is moving to canada
without her 19 year old son it's his
choice i can't change it
her husband was killed fighting in
eastern ukraine she now wants to bring
her youngest 15 year old son to canada
how do you feel about a new a whole new
start in
canada
i'm not excited about new starts i i was
afraid of bombs over my head
it seems more scary when you
can feel it when you know how it smells
burnt people important land i don't want
my child live like that demetro blinoff
is also moving for his children
but was forced to leave his parents
behind i don't know where we can
come back to to see them again many
countries are accepting ukrainian
refugees but blenoff cited canada's
natural beauty its large ukrainian
diaspora and most importantly it's far
away from russia it's really safe
country like
for for a family these ukrainians will
receive a visa allowing them to work or
study in canada for three years which
could potentially be extended depending
on the size of the family they'll also
receive a few thousand dollars to get
started and after that they'll likely
need to rely on support from their new
canadian community and the community of
moncton appears ready to respond
the flight touched down to enthusiastic
applause
and the ukrainian passengers stepped off
the plane and on to canadian soil
welcome to canada thank you
how does it feel
it's actually feel great
almost unbelievable
now we are here they were met at the
airport by an army of volunteers and in
some cases an emotional embrace
[Applause]
there are so many citizens who have just
stepped up there's a free store in every
major city people have given massive
donations they'll now receive help
finding work a place to live and if
needed counseling services
the end of a long and dangerous journey
and a chance for a fresh start
jeff semple global news moncton new
brunswick
there has been no fresh start for
thousands of people from afghanistan
that canada promised to take in we said
we'd bring forty thousand afghans here
after the taliban took over the country
fewer than fifteen thousand have arrived
as abigail beeman reports nearly three
thousand applicants have been vetted and
cleared as having worked for canada in
afghanistan but remain mired in
bureaucratic red tape still fearing for
their lives
we are practically the living dead too
afraid for his life to speak on camera
one man in afghanistan tells us he's
fighting two battles on one front with
the taliban on the other canada's
immigration department global news has
seen documentation proving he worked for
canada in multiple roles this email
shows the department of national defense
verified his information and sent it to
immigration months ago he's heard
nothing in a statement he says the
government altogether doesn't give a
damn about us being left here to die and
live in desperation while always
thinking what may happen how and where
it may happen and constantly checking
our 360 surroundings and looking at
every rifle holder with suspicion as if
he can see through me and grasp my past
with a blink and is about to unleash his
inner beast on me people could be that
really slaughters like like animals i'm
sorry to say that there is no rule of
law there is no political order there is
no judicial order the government has
heard that message over and over since
august what the heck is going on with
immigration what sort of chaos is going
on in there in may senior dnd officials
testified they vetted 3
800 afghans like the man whose story
we're sharing that had an enduring
relationship with with the canadian
armed forces and forwarded them to
immigration but only 900 less than a
quarter were accepted the ndp alleges
the remaining 2
900 files were lost they cannot find
them they do not know where they are
and people's lives are hanging in the
balance because those applications are
not being processed the immigration
minister's office says more invitations
to apply to the special immigration
program will be issued in quote the
coming weeks i don't have any reason to
believe that any files are lost but that
comment from the minister was four weeks
ago he declined an interview with us now
his office insists those files are not
lost but no one from the office nor the
department will say what happened to
them or what's being done to fix the
problem and get this particular group of
refugees to canada donna
all right abigail beamon in ottawa thank
you
the federal government has appointed a
point person to act as a kind of liaison
between the government and indigenous
people who are searching for the dead
and missing at former residential
schools
indigenous families
and communities have a right to know
and a need to know
which children died
how they died and where the children are
buried
kimberly murray is called an independent
special interlocutor she will work with
indigenous communities to recommend ways
to strengthen federal laws to protect
and preserve burial sites found at
former residential schools the assembly
of first nations says this appointment
does not eliminate the need for an
independent criminal investigation into
what it calls those responsible for the
crimes that took place
canada's environment minister has
launched a carbon credit strategy he
says will help reach the net zero
greenhouse gas emissions target set by
the federal government it is complicated
and critics say it's not a replacement
for large emitters actually cutting
their emissions the plan starts with
rules stipulating how projects can
generate tradeable carbon credits by
capturing gas from landfills
success to for us means that we will see
municipalities we will see indigenous
communities we will see agricultural uh
entities
farmers
develop projects to reduce their their
their emission reduction level
landfills can earn offset credits for
permanently removing methane from the
atmosphere municipalities can then earn
one credit for every ton of co2
sequestered a large industrial emitter
can then buy those credits to offset
their own emissions regulated heavy
emitters can cover up to 75 percent of
their pollution payment with carbon
credits other carbon offset rules are
expected for refrigeration forestry
agriculture and direct air carbon
capture and sequestration projects
carbon offsets are controversial
environmental groups say allowing
polluters to purchase offset credits
instead of cutting their own emissions
risks undermining climate goals and does
not stop pollution from heavy emitters
canada's transport minister is promising
help is coming to airline passengers
stuck in long waits at airports he says
more than 850 new securities screening
officers have been hired
with those additions now qatar is at
nearly 100 percent of the staffing level
that it had pre-pandemic
so that's a major milestone
yes we will continue to assess the
situation and if we need to add more we
will do so
not all those officers have been trained
yet and having just traveled through
toronto pearson airport myself i can
attest to the fact extremely long wait
times are still a problem at customs
and security
the spread of monkey pox coming up the
new warning to travelers
[Music]
there's a new warning for canadian
travelers about monkey pox at least 100
cases have now been confirmed in four
provinces most cases are in quebec
health authorities are hoping this new
warning will at least help contain the
spread dan spector reports
we received a report from public health
authorities dr regina thomas has been
treating patients with monkey pox for
weeks at his montreal clinic
every morning we have christians who are
coming
for testing a little bit less this week
over 800 vaccine doses have been
delivered to vulnerable populations in
quebec the canadian epicenter of the
monkeypox outbreak canada has at least
100 cases across four provinces bc
alberta ontario and quebec where there
are at least 90. now that i got my
my shot done
i feel pretty safe as health officials
try to stop the outbreak in its tracks
canadians are now being warned to take
extra precautions when traveling abroad
the public health agency of canada
issuing a level 2 travel advisory
warning travelers that if infected while
abroad isolation might be necessary
access to health care could be limited
and coming home could be difficult the
u.s centers for disease control is
issuing similar cautions the most
important warning is if you become sick
somewhere else you're kind of on your
own there are now over a thousand cases
in 30 countries globally endemic to
parts of africa the unusual spread to
western countries including the united
kingdom spain and germany as the world
health organization concerned
the risk of monkey pox
becoming established in non-endemic
countries israel
cases are mainly among men who have had
prolonged close contact with other men
skin lesions are the most common symptom
and will go away on their own within a
few weeks but cases can be severe three
people in quebec have been hospitalized
in connection with monkey pox dr thomas
believes canadian cases will continue to
rise but medical experts are encouraged
the virus is being taken seriously if we
do the opposite which is we
underestimated and it spreads like
wildfire well we know exactly what can
happen the hope is that vaccines and
travel advisories can help halt
transmission and avoid another public
health emergency dan specter global news
montreal
ahead the chaos and questions after a
car is driven into a crowd in berlin
there's been a frightening incident in
berlin germany a car drove onto a
sidewalk crowded with people in a
popular shopping area one person has
been killed at least a dozen injured as
crystal gamansing reports police are
trying to determine if it was accidental
or intentional
for hours police and emergency workers
covered a stretch of berlin's most
popular shopping district normally a
major draw for pedestrians and tourists
instead it was mayhem wednesday when a
man in a small vehicle jumped the curb
and began driving at pedestrians it's
really pretty bad guys
john barrowman witnessed the incident
shaken he started posting on social
media about what he saw
there's a
dead body in the middle of the road of
those struck by the attacker a group of
school children enjoying an outing with
their teacher the teacher died at the
scene at least 14 students were injured
some critically i had such a spy light
berlin's top security official offered
condolences to the teacher's family
the vehicle at the center of the chaos
eventually came to a stop after the
driver plowed into a shop while being
escorted from the scene the man a 29
year old german armenian national asked
one onlooker for help
what's happened
no he was told you nearly killed us
the attack similar to an incident from
2016. in that case a truck was
deliberately driven into a busy
christmas market in the same part of
central berlin
13 people died in that attack it was
ultimately linked to islamic extremism
german police have yet to say whether
they believe today's act was intentional
crystal gomson global news london
american olympic gold medalist simone
biles is among dozens of women who are
seeking more than one billion dollars
u.s from the fbi for failing to stop
convicted sexual abuser larry nassar
lawyers said the federal agency failed
to act when it first received
allegations against him in 2015 leaving
the former sports doctor free to
continue to target girls and young women
for more than a year approximately 90
claimants say they were sexually
assaulted by nassar
next why canada's world cup excitement
is getting kicked offside by controversy
there should be nothing but excitement
now that canada's national men's soccer
team has qualified for the world cup but
there are problems eric sorenson reports
on the trouble for the team on the road
to the sport's biggest competition not
even a game in the snow could cool off
the excitement over canada's men's
soccer team winning a place in the world
cup for the first time in 36 years
but a chill has descended as fans showed
up for a tune-up match with panama
sunday in vancouver
the barricades came out signs were
removed the doors closed
the game's canceled a stunning
disappointment for fans took the ferry
over here
now we'll take the ferry back and a
second straight embarrassment for the
team
canada soccer first scheduled a game
with iran i think it's it's it wasn't a
very good idea to invite the iranian
soccer team here to canada under
pressure from ottawa and families of
those killed in iran's missile attack
two years ago that game was cancelled
and then the players walked out before
the panama game in a dispute with canada
soccer over the role of the players in
the organization and over money what
they were in terms of popularity
and in terms of profitability in 2018 is
far far different from what they are now
i really think the onus is on canada
stalker to be a lot more transparent
it's estimated the team will get 10 to
15 million dollars from fifa for making
the world cup canada soccer proposed 30
percent of that for the men and 30 for
the women's national team but the men's
team wanted more and canada soccer
balked
and i can't
accept an offer that will put our
organization in a financial position
that is untenable so the players didn't
suit up not a good look for canada to
turn away two international teams in a
matter of days then i apologize to the
panamanians they're our friends and for
the canadian players a major distraction
at a crucial time
it hurts it does we're down to just over
10 training sessions that canada is
going to have
between now and the world cup the
players are now training again and will
play in a nation's cup match with
curacao thursday night so after stumbles
in negotiations the team hopes to put
its best foot forward on the playing
field eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday tonight's here canada is the
high-level bridge in lethbridge alberta
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
you